there's other strange things going on
like unelected Elites at the world
economic Forum talking about climate
change digital IDs these are the same
people that set the covert narrative
there's Bill Gates buying up Farmland
the world you know the world economic
Forum even said that by 2030 you owe
nothing you'll be happy and you'll eat
bugs so my question too is what do you
think the purpose is behind all of this
and do you want to eat bugs and owe
nothing and do you think you'll be happy
so you know I'm assuming if I were to
come into your office right behind your
desk if I'm a betting man I'm willing to
bed there's probably a nice poster or
painting of Klaus Schwab right behind
your oh absolutely it's actually above
my bed it's actually above my bed
there's this this painting of this guy
but again going back to it here's what
I'll say to you so this is a complete
different view that I have of this so
say you go to a party okay and you're
sitting there and there's a punk who's a
bully but he doesn't know who you are
and he's bullying in everybody okay
pushing people around making fun of them
in a weird way like in stuff like
there's a difference between being
sarcastic and a bully he's being a dick
he's being an [__] he's being a true
bully right how long will you let it go
see this is not really your element and
your environment you're just somebody
that was invited maybe you let it go for
10 minutes you're like yeah it's not
it's his house I'm not going to say
nothing 20 minutes 30 minutes an hour
he's still going drinks gets worse gets
worse gets worse and then he comes to
you and then you're eventually going to
be like yeah no we're not doing this
very simple okay we're not doing this
you know everybody has a limit some
people are a little bit more tolerant
than others are this whole concept of
what they're pushing there are a lot of
people that will buy into that they will
own nothing and be happy and now you see
the message of minimalism and it's going
to be okay and yesterday we're at church
and the pastor's up on stage and talking
about who cares about living in a six
thousand square foot house I know he
people that are 10 times more happy or
living in a shack studio with five kids
and they're okay life is not about this
life is not about that and you know
what's crazy I'm looking around the
place I'm like this is a 200 million
dollar facility who gave this money to
you where did this money come from
didn't you do like a campaign to raise
200 million bucks so who are you talking
to who's your audience like who do you
think you lose when you talk like that
to congregation you think you're a
person that's sitting at this church
that maybe is willing to give you 10
million bucks 5 million bucks is saying
absolutely let me give it to this or do
you think that person takes and says
maybe you don't value somebody like me
part of your church I get the whole
concept about you know a poor man has
more likely of going into heaven than
the rich man and I totally understand
I've heard that story million we've all
heard the story before but messaging
matters
in whatever message you have uh one time
I was asking my guys I say we have an
audience of 100 people and you're up
here trying to sell stocks mutual funds
and bonds hypothetically we have 10
different of you that give presentations
to this hundred people they're all
qualified buyers but you got 10
different different presenters that give
a presentation to these under buyers
will the same amount of buyers buy from
all of you and everyone's like
no
perfect tell me why look uh I don't know
I want you to actually think about this
so maybe the person that said yes to you
said no to me why did they say no to me
but they say yes to you and they
invested two million dollars with you
why did they say no to me everything's
about messaging messaging will attract
victims if everybody around you is a
crap magnet it's because of your
messaging you're a crap magnet if
everybody around you is somebody that's
going after and wanting to do something
big with their lives it's a reflection
of your messaging if everybody in your
political party are the ones that are
always complaining whining that's what
you're selling if everybody in your
political party is independent doing
things that's part of messaging as well
so maybe we need to take inventory and
realize this messaging by Klaus Schwab
or the world economic Forum that they're
going out they're saying what they're
saying their messaging is maybe going to
work for the first six months 12 months
maybe five years maybe 10 years then all
of a sudden there's going to be an
eruption of people that are going to get
up and say wait wait those who
specialize in bullying the bully and
he's going to realize do these people I
can't bully I can control these masses I
can't control these 28 people and these
28 people are way more powerful than
these 20 2.8 billion people all it takes
is 2.28 people that specialize in
bullying the bully to get up and say
Klaus knock it off you've lost your mind
no people don't feel that way and the
other 2.0 2.18 billion they're going to
be like
what the hell was I thinking about don't
worry you're not alone a lot of people
fell for it they have no clue what
they're doing you want to be free trust
me you have your own individual dreams
this right here is only mine you have
yours he has his yeses this is my
signature this is your signature we all
have dreams some big some small we all
have them to say you're going to take
away my ability to fight for my dreams
where the hell is my identity how do I
leave my Mark here not your mark not his
mark my mark Klaus has left his Mark how
about the rest of the people it's it's
an idea that's going to get exposed and
people are going to wake up when they're
gonna say this guy's lost his mind they
have no clue what they're talking about
it's going to happen it's really
optimistic I'm somewhat a little bit
more cynical I get it I feel like
tyranny happens gradually and I feel
like power and money corrupts so I don't
know if those 28 people are really gonna
what's gonna happen with those 28 people
wherever those 28 people go eventually
the two point 8 billion people will go
meaning so I I lived in Iran okay say
Khomeini doesn't show up to Iran Say
Jimmy Carter helps to Shah and Kissinger
they kept their promises and the Shah
got help from U.S and there is no
Revolution Khomeini doesn't go to Iran
what happens those three thousand
political prisoners are not let out and
9 11 doesn't take place right but Iran
lost many of us but many of us came to
the states we went to Australia we went
here we went different places we're
gonna go contribute to the next Society
the types of cloud swap that do what
they do they're eventually going to deal
with people like us we're not going away
the Market's filled with people that are
Fighters you think Elon Musk 10 years
ago had any plans of buying Twitter like
you think that was part of his game plan
how much you think that increased during
covet how much you think the silencing
increased in covet you think his plan on
his business plan was one day I want to
buy Twitter from my friend Jack Dorsey
now I don't see that being on his dream
list or a business plan I just see that
they pushed him so much he says don't
worry I'm here I'm going to buy this now
here's what I'd love to see if you
really want to see this guy make people
lose their minds I'd love to see Along
by CNN for six billion hours I'd like to
see it I'd love to see him buy CNN by
the way that's all it's going to cost by
the way it's a six billion dollar
company right now in shambles he can
probably buy it for five billion dollars
make the offer of seven billion dollars
buy it and go do what Ted Turner
originally wanted to do with your
stories from both sides go fulfill that
guy's prophecy not the mess they've
created at CNN today so but guys like
that 6 billion is not a lot of money
people need to see what musk did other
billionaires who have that kind of money
to say okay if musk bought that what am
I going to buy what are you going to buy
and maybe for you you know you may be
like well I don't have billions well how
can you contribute you're doing that
right now with your channel you're
getting people to think people know who
you are you've created a platform you're
getting people to start questioning
themselves and you're from London yeah
so the audience that you're bringing is
a different audience but I think more
people are going to wake up and say just
this doesn't add up and that fight's
going to continue are some countries
going to take a fall and lose a decade
two three decades because they're buying
to show up 100 are those leaders still
going to rise up yes and everybody else
is going to follow those people every
time it does every time that happens so
these leaders predominantly tend to be
men and I think you know you know mask
is a perfect example and I think
there's a huge war on masculinity right
now I've personally watched the
feminization of men and I'm only in my
20s but I've seen it in the last 10
years
um and I know you've spoken a lot about
this with your five hour podcast with
Andrew Tate so why do you think they're
trying to feminize men do you think it
has something to do with not allowing
the likes of Elon Musk to rise up and
sort of put a stop to the Klaus Schwab
agenda
it could be you know it's
um look you know why I love capitalism
you know why socialists hate capitalism
think about it
why do socialists hate capitalism
because it's freaking hard yeah it's so
hard to build a business it's so
difficult it's so annoying it could cost
you your marriage you're gonna miss out
on a lot of parties you're going to miss
out on a lot of great memories you're
gonna miss out as a capitalist it's not
easy they think it's easy it's so
incredibly hard elon's most liked tweet
it's got like six or seven million likes
he said so I work 16 hours a day for 360
days for 30 years or whatever he puts
and people still call me lucky right you
know no he's not worth 300 billion
dollars because the guy got lucky did he
get lucky throughout the process of
course he did but this thing is hard so
you know we have a hard time looking at
people and saying I can never be like
you and that's okay I can never be
LeBron James as a basketball player
never I can't jump 46 inches I I don't
have that vertical ability I don't have
it right there's a lot of things we
can't do and that's fine there's certain
things LeBron cannot do that I can do he
just can't do what things I can do and
that's fine right there's certain things
you can't to do that I can do you have
to be okay with that but there are
certain things I can't do that you can
do and I'm certainly very okay with that
when it becomes about you saying no I
want to be able to do what equal in
every aspect of life you're full of
yourself you're naive and not only are
you naive you're incredibly arrogant to
think that
foreign